[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who cold weathers the storm
every friday
to bring you a breakdown on the
mandalorian this week's entry is
directed by the main man apollo creed
himself
and though it gets a little rocky at
times that doesn't mean that the episode
isn't a complete knockout
mando's ship is left on a knife's edge
after the events of last week
and thus he takes the racer to navarro
in order to fix it
i guess that's what happens when when
you get help from someone who buys their
sweaters at jc penney's anyway
i think we're all kind of used to the
idea that when the series teases a new
character
that they don't appear in the next
episode but i have faith that we will
see ahsoka next time
mando reunites with grief koga and a
woman who goes by the name
beep bop boop on social media in order
to take down an imperial base
the episode carries some big reveals and
a cliffhanger that we
definitely need to talk about but before
all that we have to go back to where we
last left our heroes
you may remember that episode 3 ended
with a piece of debris flying off the
razor crest
and it becomes immediately clear in this
episode that things are a little worse
for wear
the child is attempting to fix the
wiring on the ship and they have this
adorable moment where mano tries to tell
him to reinsert the red wire into where
the blue one is
i got a lot of vibes of rocket doing
something similar to baby groot and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
and it really is an adorable scene
unfortunately the child gets
electrocuted
and he and mando settle and have some
soup i thought mando was actually going
to remove his helmet
after all the stuff with bulkitan but
unfortunately he doesn't
as this is still away cutting navarro
and we jump back to the armrest lair and
see that the mythosaur crest above the
door has been removed
she's nowhere to be seen but i'm sure
she will return later down the line as
she's quite an important character
the base is being looted by some
aqualish and these are the same species
as pondababba who you may remember from
a new hope
cara arrives and takes them out before
rescuing a ferret-like creature
that becomes her new best friend who
needs baby yoda when when you've got
something else that loves food and is a
complete nightmare now i love how cara
is also a marshal on navarro this
aesthetic was of course set up by cobb
van in episode 1 of season 2 and in the
wake of the empire's collapse
there has been a real power struggle on
many planets
everyone's vying for control in this
power vacuum and it's nice that they
carry on the motif here
maybe if the farm town in the first
season had a fully appointed martial
then things would have never got so bad
for them
and who knows mando might even retire to
that planet
and become their sheriff one day mando
arrives and is greeted by karger and
korra
and two of grief's best people are put
on the job of fixing the razor
now one of them looks ever so suspicious
and it's revealed at the end of the
episode that they placed a tracking
device
on board the vessel so that moth gideon
could follow them
he obviously wants the child but could
also be after ahsoka
which emando is now going to lead him
directly to
i'll talk about that in just a bit but i
love how much more vibrant navarro looks
these days
the streets are full of people and we
can also spot a monument to ig-11 in the
square
who was of course instrumental in saving
the planet in addition to these new
trading opportunities
there's also been a boost in education
and we witness a school being taught by
a protocol droid
the child is put in a class and even
steals some macaroons from another
student
oh yeah did no one ever tell you a share
yeah you're expelled
you scumbag now it's not too long until
mando is reintroduced to a familiar face
namely one of the mithril that mano took
in in season 1.
since his capture the character has been
working off his debt with grief
and he still has difficulty seeing out
of his left eye
because of the carbonite he was encased
in you may remember that in return of
the jedi
upon being freed han solo was blind for
quite a while
and this is obviously a side effect of
the hibernation process
anyway getting to the point of the
episode grief wants navarro to be a
trade anchor for the entire sector
which will free the planet but in order
to do this they need to destroy the last
imperial base on it and thus they head
out they plan to overload the reactor
and travel through a canyon until they
reach the highly unguarded front door
now mithril is initially a bit worried
about joining them
but kara manages to scare him into
coming by mentioning the lava tides
you may remember that in episode 8 of
season 1 when our heroes were heading
through the underground of the planet
that they had to sail on a lava barge i
love how they keep these consistencies
up across the seasons
and it's nice remembering that all these
planets have certain characteristics
after mando takes the shortcut and the
others take the elevator
they make their way to the reactor they
use a code cylinder to open a door
and this looks extremely similar to one
of the rods that r2d2 had so that he
could access imperial tech
upon arriving at the reactor you also
see that it echoes the tractor beam
control from the death star
mithral says that they should really put
up a guardrail there
and this was actually a joke in blue
harvest which was parodying star wars
namely how the empire never put any
safety precautions in place
after depowering it things start to go
to hell and the episode really kicks it
up a notch as the group tried to escape
the base
whilst tackling the imperial forces on
their way
now a big reveal in the entry comes when
they arrive at a cloning lab
and discover a message from dr pershing
along with some bodies that look like
they may either be
snoke or emperor palpatine it's
difficult to make out
but what we do learn is that the empire
has been attempting to clone four
sensitive beings
and that that is why they need the child
throughout star wars law
it was said that one could not copy
creatures who possessed an ability to
wield the force
however rise of skywalker and did this
by having palpatine and snoke
both revealed as duplicates now what i'm
guessing is that the empire learned how
to clone the bodies of these characters
and then using the blood of baby odor
they were able to place force-wielding
abilities into them
pershing does say that initially there
were promising effects
but the body rejected the blood of the
child this led to a number of failures
and it's unlikely that things would
change pershing warns that the
volunteers shouldn't attempt this
procedure anymore
i'm guessing that this could be snoke or
that it's more likely palpatine
who would clone himself before then
carrying out the process on someone else
now of course most bodies are going to
reject the blood of baby yoda
as he's not a humanoid but someone who
is is a sucker to know
i actually think that mando might lead
the empire directly to her
and then she could be used to give the
midichlorians from her body to palpatine
and thus create a new line of sith
ahsoka doesn't identify as either jedi
or sith
so this would be the perfect place to
start again
all these are just theories here but we
know that pershing was a cloner as
theorized
and that the empire were attempting to
harvest the blood of the child in order
to create force sensitive clones
it's at this point that mando also
learns morph gideon is alive
and sure it's something we've had
confirmed for some time but the
character
himself did need to discover it mando
heads back to the child and the others
run through the base
chased by stormtroopers it leads to an
awesome action scene with the troopers
saying that they are blastum
which is a play on it's them blast them
from a new hope
blast car jacks a troop transport that
was helpfully pointed out to us earlier
in the episode
and after escaping the base they're
pursued by thai fighters
i love how as they drive off the edge
mithral and koga are screaming
bakara is actually sitting there
smirking which is a nice bit of
attention to detail
for for how her character would be
speeder bikes initially follow them
before tie fighters arrive
and it leads to an awesome action scene
that i'm sure means carl weathers will
be directing another episode
because he does such a good job also the
ties sit with a similar sort of
apparatus to moff gideon's in the first
season
so i'm guessing that this is now just
standard for the ships at this point
the ties completely batter the transport
and when all hope seems lost
mando arrives in the razor and blows
them out of the sky
now things seem like they're gonna be
alright and captain carson
actually appears at the end you may
remember him from episode 2
and the x-wing pilot likely came with
wolf aka
dave filoni the creator of the clone
wars though he's not
seen another x-wing does join carson's
so he can make some assumptions and
filoni was probably just busy that day
however his character wasn't and and
that is my head cunning now
anyway carson buys the story they give
him and he also attempts to recruit cara
into the alliance
as we know she was a rebel shock trooper
and still bears the tattoo of them on
her face
now she did turn away from them after
she saw the politics first hand
and it doesn't really seem like anything
has changed memories of alderaan are
stirred up for her
and as we know from a new hope that
planet was destroyed by the death star
cora says she lost everyone and it's a
really touching moment
but hey at least she has a ferret now
now carson says there's something going
on out there
and it is likely that the empire are
carrying out experiments in the far
reaches of space
so that they fly under the radar of the
rebels the events that lead to the rise
of skywalker are definitely teased here
and who knows if we will learn more
about what's going on we also know
pershing is alive
so it doesn't seem like the cloning
experiments are going to stop
anytime soon as mando and the child had
do ahsoka
we discover that the moth has been
tracking them and the episode ends with
him following the ship
whilst preparing his forces now these
look slightly different to what he had
in season one
and i kind of think that they might even
be genetically altered
i don't know all the ins and outs of all
the lore concerning them
so make sure you let me know if you do
but from this it almost seems like he's
building a brand new army
after the last ones failed to capture
the child anyway it's a great way to end
the episode
and if you're still not subscribed to
the channel then what the heck ins are
you doing
we do videos like this each and every
day so if you've enjoyed it then please
drop a thumbs up
and the force will be with you always
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase two box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november
so make sure you get involved okay so
going forward
i think we will finally meet ahsoka and
actually see some proper lightsaber
fighting
in the series we know that the character
is on the forest planet of corvus
so will be a nice little change up as a
locale
now with this i think we will also learn
the truth about the child
the cloning was brought up here and we
know from his age that baby oda was
alive
during order 66 thus ahsoka will likely
know where he came from
and which jedi fled with him and hid him
from the empire
she will of course recognize him as
yoda's kind i think we will
finally discover the truth about his
origins anyway
those are all just theories but i'd love
to hear yours in the comments section
below
you enjoyed this yeah i know i'm asking
again but please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of who ahsoka to know is
we tell you everything you need to know
about to know
so yeah great puns as well anyway if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come check this on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul i'll see you next time
hopefully yeah take care peace
just